there are a small number of gutsy
Hollywood stars who insist on doing
their own stunt work but because most
a-listers are happy to hand the really
dangerous stuff over to the
professionals stunt doubles are always
in demand in Tinseltown unfortunately
not every stunt has a happy ending
brushes with death are an occupational
hazard for Hollywood stunt doubles and
these were some of the most hazardous
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 Warner Brothers tried to use
practical effects whenever possible in
their Harry Potter series especially
when it came to broomsticks that didn't
mean the studio was happy to put its
star witches and wizards on those
broomsticks however stuntman david
holmes doubled for daniel radcliffe and
many scenes all the way back to the
first film during Deathly Hallows Part 1
Holmes was filming a flying stunt when
he was yanked from his broom and slammed
into a wall before falling to the ground
the accident broke his neck and left him
paralyzed at the age of 25 Holmes told
the mirror I remember slipping in and
out of consciousness because of the pain
levels I knew I had really done some
damage Radcliffe himself thinks of
Holmes as a friend rather than a
colleague and hosted a charity auction
to help Holmes pay for his medical bills
Back to the Future Part 2 the hoverboard
scene is one of the most memorable
moments from Back to the Future Part 2
though for stunt performer Cheryl
wheeler it brings back painful memories
since she was almost killed shooting the
sequence
one stunt woman had already quit over
the scene and wheeler became concerned
after a handful of last-minute changes
were made to the rig after being accused
of getting cold feet the stunt
coordinator threatened to put a male
stunt performer in her clothes for the
scene being new to the business and
wanting to make an impression she
reluctantly agreed instead of crashing
through the sugar glass window wheeler
collided with a stone pillar and was
dropped 30 feet onto the concrete below
missing the fall mats entirely fellow
stunt performer Gary Morgan recalled in
the book we don't need roads I got up
and Cheryl was laying on the concrete
and the pool of blood by her head was
getting bigger I thought she was dead
fortunately Cheryl was quickly back in
action into still performing stunts as
recently as 2015 The Expendables 2
countless henchmen are maimed and killed
during the many explosions that take
place throughout Sylvester Stallone's
Expendables films but one of them
actually claimed life for real stuntman
Kunlun was fatally injured during the
filming of a scene in Bulgaria involving
an inflatable raft for the Expendables 2
while Lu's life could not be saved his
partner during the stunt knew of Sun
somehow escaped with his according to
court papers Sun sustained damage to his
nervous system neck head body and arms
which left him in great mental physical
and nervous pain and suffering the stunt
performer sued Millenial films for
$25,000
as well as the cost of his lengthy
hospital treatment and recovery today
Sun continues to work in the stunt
Department of films like ant-man and
Logan Resident Evil the final chapter
star Milla Jovovich said it was a
miracle her double survived an incident
that took place on the set of 2016 s
Resident Evil the final chapter which
left a British stunt woman in a coma
according to a Facebook post by yo vich
my incredibly talented stunt double
Olivia Jackson collided with a camera
crane while performing a motorcycle
stunt in a put her in the hospital with
severe multiple injuries after she
regained consciousness Jackson also took
to Facebook to reveal the horrifying
extent of the damage which included a
degloved face brain swelling an
amputated thumb and a missing piece of
bone she called the incident quote not
her funnest day on set in the end one of
Jackson's arms had to be amputated the
resilient Brit posted a picture of her
twisted upper body on her Instagram feed
in January 2017 claiming that her
off-centered neck is the most painful
part saying I don't mean to moan but
some
times I just want to crawl out of my own
skin and all the pains in it for what
it's worth she seems to be keeping in
good spirits about her injuries The
Hangover Part two Australian stuntman
Scott MacLean was doubling for funny man
at Helm's in The Hangover Part two when
the stunt drivers involved in the film's
car chase reportedly got their marks
wrong and McLane's head was hit by a
truck
he suffered a critical head injury
forcing hospital staff to put him in a
medically induced coma McClain was
feared dead by his colleagues after the
impact and while he ultimately escaped
with his life his lawyers claim he
suffered permanent brain injuries his
wife commented there was so much damage
he was a mess he used to look after me
now it's my turn to look after him for a
change
McLean's life will never be the same
despite extensive therapy but today he
speaks openly and positively about his
recovery thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]